[Music]
the train with you
wheredid broke as a bottle of wine come
from I love that that's my favorite line
of song so my concept was rich love but
then you also need one or two lines that
are just sticky that like you can't
explain what it means or why but yeah
when I sat down listening this guitar
and was writing the first line I had was
I remember feelin broke because a bottle
of wine I was referring to like to buck
chuck yeah it's not necessarily broken
bottle of wine but like $2.00 wine for
those you don't know I had so many
nights so many nights Grey's Anatomy and
to buck chuck only et was behind the
scenes of one Republic's new rich love
music video with Ryan Tedder set on the
famous fourth Street bridge in Los
Angeles through house party the neighbor
behind Katherine Heigl did behind us hi
Katherine if you watch and her now
husband Josh Kelly
so we threw house party in like half the
cast of Grey's Anatomy showed up and
this is right when it was like popping
and what was gonna be just like a nice
little get-together with 1015 people
turn into 50 people turned into 60
spilled out into our front yard music
blasting cops show up
neighbors furious and so that's the song
it's like I literally just recounting
all these memories so though what you do
when you're in your 20s and you're you
know you live in New York or LA or
London and you you're broke
[Music]
earlier this year you posted a message
to fans on Facebook about the whole
touring and process how it can be
overwhelming why was it important for
you to share that message we came off
the biggest album of our career negative
went straight into making another album
did a bunch of lead up and at that point
I was on empty I remember just thinking
oh crap like I'm I'm I'm toast
I'm so done then we drop an album and
and within six weeks I go dark like I
lilies like stop talking about the album
I stop promoting the single that's out I
kill the chance of any other song coming
off the album because any more work any
more being gone any more grinding I I
was gonna quit music I was literally
gonna just be like screw it I'm out like
I mean I'm done the most dangerous thing
to do in entertainment is music acting
is to get to the point where you
actually aren't having fun lutely i woke
up one morning I was in the couch and I
just started typing I was like here's
what's going on we've put it out put out
an album we didn't promote we made merch
that we literally burned or didn't sell
maybe we killed all of it no resonated
with you and that whole Bieber thing
went down to right oh I knew exactly
when he pulled out on that tour I was
like good move good move you've been
doing it for two years
stop before you hate it go home take
time pretty set start again
[Music]
to see